I need that more belief what's the
problem with everybody it's like the
problem is belief you don't believe in
yourself do the next thing you think the
problem is how how do I X that's not the
problem the problem is you don't believe
in yourself to do the how I can give you
all the hows in the world but until you
believe in your ability to do the how
you're not going to do the thing Elon
Musk takes over Twitter everybody says
like Twitter's burning and going away
and he just lost half his staff this guy
tweets out I'm sitting here dealing with
my dumb ass imposter syndrome meanwhile
Elon Musk is out there like breaking
everything and chewing on the wires
until the whole company falls apart he's
not even defending himself like he cares
zero about what people think about him
he's like putting mean pictures up of
Jesus and like all sorts of just random
stuff he's not even trying to defend
himself like I wouldn't bet against Elon
like he's done this he's the richest man
in the world series he has a plan he's
just he's not explaining the plan he's
like I don't care I don't need to
explain to you what my plan is I'm just
going to go off and do it I respect the
fact that he just doesn't care what
people think about him I was filming
here I had this guy who was all about
his gear and fancy gear and and he had
this like red dragon I don't know how
much a red dragon cost like insanely
expensive camera at the time was like
eight years ago or something and like to
make it work he had to be at this end of
the studio and I was like way back here
and we filmed an entire month worth of
content in one day and then when he got
home he said Evan I am so sorry the
microphone wasn't working and I didn't
check properly before we recorded So he
says we need to refilm this because it's
terrible and I said well do we have any
audio it's like yeah but it's only the
auto captured by my camera and the
camera mic sucks so I said you know what
we're gonna publish post I don't care
like we make mistakes and we go so for
an entire month on my channel I don't
know what they did my editor hated me
she's like what is this crap you're
giving me like this looks so bad we
still post anyway so we posted for an
entire month and some of those videos
are actually like barely big videos on a
channel and the comments were just rough
it's like Evan why are you filming in a
toilet Evan can I buy you a 50
microphone so like you should be able to
afford this by now on your YouTube
channel it's just like devastating
first question for you yeah we have been
in this journey for five-ish years now a
lot of what I expected would happen is
vastly different than what has happened
yeah welcome what were the expectations
versus the reality of where you are
today and how much of your day-to-day
life
did you not expect at all what time
frame are we looking at for this
question so the past five years or like
from beginning to the first five years
from beginning when you first started
Walt Disney in your fine suit when you
started this journey can you take us
back to what your expectations were I
mean you've spoken with Tony Robbins all
the greats is that a surprise to you
what is that like so at the very
beginning going back what was that 2009
I
I would have said
I'd be doing a lot more speaking I would
have said it'd be like speaking every
week in a different city or like
multiple times per week in different
cities I would have said it have
I guess I do have four or five bucks I
would have said it would have had like
multiple books I guess we made that
happen I knew what I saw so at the time
I only saw like YouTube wasn't a thing
so I didn't think YouTube would ever be
a thing because I only knew what I saw
so who did I see well I saw Tony Robbins
lead an event so that okay I want a lead
events I saw
people writing big books so I thought
okay I'm going to write I'm going to
write books and that's going to be my
thing YouTube then started to take off
and I also realized personally I didn't
want to be on the road
three days a week and come back like
that's still a life a lot of people lead
and just wasn't interesting for me so
even now I try to pick one thing per
month to go to which is a stress because
people want me like a bunch of different
things such as the World opening up now
so yeah I mean I don't really look
backwards that way so that was
interesting but that was probably it
like I imagine I'd be running events
um and speaking
300 days a year and like that do you
ever have the moment where you so you
don't really reflect you don't ever have
the moment where you wake up and say wow
this is so weird
uh well I mean he asked me that a
similar question when you guys last came
up here is like how much time do you
spend in the past versus the president
versus future I think I said like zero
percent past 85 President 50 future so I
don't really look backwards almost at
all unless there's some lesson that I
can learn
um but typically no so wow is this weird
um
not really I don't get caught up I think
if I'm if I'm focusing on anything right
now it's been a lot more just uh
gratitude for where we're at so this
actually bothers Dina a lot is what
where I'll look at our our dogs you guys
met our dogs this morning
um and they're like five years old four
years old and I said you know in 10
years like imagine 10 years Teemo may
not even be alive or we definitely won't
have this kind of energy and she said oh
that's very she's giving me a nasty look
right now she's like that is not cool
like why are you talking about this it's
like but but it makes me love him so
much more now like it makes me
appreciate the energy he has and I'll
Chase his toy and he'll jump on people
or in 10 years like that's that's not
going to be a reality so if anything
I'll I'll like future pace and then
think back on the present as opposed to
present day looking back on the past
so again uh this is about the top five
things that you wish you knew at the
beginning okay as an entrepreneur
so you're very future oriented and
present oriented and you don't reflect
on the past that often uh I guess my
question for you would be this
do you think that future orientation
came naturally or is that something you
had to work on uh well I'm much more
present than I am future right so still
like 85 present and 15 future
and zero percent pass maybe one percent
pass I don't know but I don't really
spend a lot of time there I don't know
that I spent a lot of time I didn't
consciously work on it I guess to to
your what was the old name of your show
hypercon hyper conscious right exactly
so I wasn't hyper conscious about about
it um I think as a result of all the
people that I've studied and hung out
with
a lot of their messages a lot of times
will come to present moment
how to how to be grateful how to stick
around it how to stay focused on like
what you're doing right now as opposed
to the impracticality of looking
backwards and like oh I wish I did this
or I wish I was there I wish I played
bigger sooner or whatever because it
doesn't unless it's unless it's
encouraging you now to go take action it
doesn't doesn't serve you so I didn't
consciously go after it but I think as a
as a byproduct of the things I was
chasing and learning and being around
these people like that was a unintended
consequence of like the advice that I
was receiving because they all seemed to
think that way what do you think your
life would have ended up being like if
you didn't find your one word and go all
in on it I have no idea dude well think
about this stuff so what would my life
be like if I didn't find my one word and
I what and you didn't go all in on it
because as an early entrepreneur if
people don't find their one word
I don't know that I would know the
difference you know
like if I was if I didn't find believe
when I did and I never found it I'd be
living a different life I mean I would
still be an entrepreneur because I I
didn't think about your one word until
how long ago was that five years ago
how long have you been an entrepreneur
since 19. I'm 42. so like I didn't
figure that out until
definitely passed a halfway point of me
already being an entrepreneur like 19
was my first real business before that I
was doing baseball cards and like garage
sales and so I had a lot of
entrepreneurial Tendencies but I never
actually called myself an entrepreneur I
had a real business
so I don't I didn't have believe as a
something I could identify I think it
was still in me but I didn't have it as
a path or a compass or a road map to be
able to guide me so I would still be an
entrepreneur I'd still be doing my stuff
and I would probably be
I think I'd still be happy I mean I was
a happy guy before I just wouldn't have
as much
growth or as much impact but I may not
know the difference you know like I'm
sure even Evan now if I made a couple
decisions differently five years ago or
yesterday like I would be further ahead
and having more impact and but I know
the difference because I didn't I didn't
make that choice so I don't really spend
time kind of stressing out about what I
could have done like if I invited you
guys up last year maybe I'd be on a
whole other Next Level now you know I
don't know but I don't spend time like
wishing like hey I sent you this time
and here you are so here we are well
this okay this is more present yeah what
is something
today that you're surprised you're
either still struggling with or dealing
with that you expected would potentially
be in the past
I think the willingness to admit that I
still struggle with belief
was maybe didn't cut like maybe three
years ago
I struggled with how do I how am I the
believe God but I still struggle with
self-belief and I just written a book
you know and talking about figuring your
one word and all this stuff and built to
serve I think was three years ago
um and I really struggled with how am I
still struggling with belief when I'm
supposed to be the believe guy not to
the extent where it became full-on
imposter syndrome but more of ah this is
really interesting
that I still struggle with this even
though this is what I'm teaching other
people as well and then I I it led to a
great realization that this is actually
everybody
you know like if you get what's here's
persistence uh resilience resilience
it's like on the other side like you
need more resilience you know like we
all it's it's the push to the next level
always and it actually then became a
nice unlock because
to look at you and say dude like you
need to have more resilience other
people would say but you're already the
most resilient person I know like that's
crazy like no no like you're still like
halfway there like you barely scratch
the surface of what resilience actually
looks like right the stuff that you
still complain about the stuff that
still holds you back the things that
you're still not doing is still just
more resilient and and that's like
that's not a negative thing it's a
loving push forward and so same thing
with me the belief like believe is still
the thing that I need the most how do
you differentiate between imposter
syndrome and I'm not
I'm not there yet we had a conversation
downstairs where somebody said I'm not
I'm a hypocrite if I share the message
because I haven't mastered the message
yet how did you deal with that you share
what you know
if I'm trying to help people work out I
feel like I'm an imposter because I'm
not you guys are experts at that meal
plans and I can mean I can share what
I'm doing but I don't pretend to be any
kind of expert but if I did then I would
feel like an imposter because I haven't
really done as much work right so you
can only teach what you know
I look at it like a staircase that we're
climbing and every time you take a step
on the staircase you can help somebody
get to the step that you're at but the
goal is to always keep climbing so you
know you're at step 40 and Tony Robbins
is at step 8 000 and most people are
Step Zero so you can help people get to
step 39 but you can't help somebody get
to step 42 because you haven't done that
yet so actual imposter syndrome
is when you're trying to teach something
that you actually don't know what you're
talking about because you haven't done
the thing and I think you should feel
like an imposter like if I'm out there
selling workout secrets and stuff and I
don't look ripped it's like well you
should feel like an imposter like you're
you're a scam artist you're selling
something that you don't actually you
haven't done as opposed to
no you've actually done a lot of work so
you know to that person I would say well
we're always climbing and growing there
is no end you don't want to stop
climbing because if you stop progressing
you're actually going to hate your life
you don't want to hit the top of the
mountain climbing forever cool and every
time you climb you want to help somebody
up get to the step you are you know
behind you
um and you are ahead of where you were
before
you know
Kevin from five years ago you have a lot
to teach that guy
Alan from four years ago we've allowed
to teach like if you go back and talk to
the guys who like episode one of your
podcast is like so much you could tell
those two about how to make a better
podcast than episode one right you could
you could just brain dump 28 things that
those two need to work on right so but
you're not Joe Rogan and you're not like
whoever you look up to in the podcast
World cool but you don't need to be to
help Alan Kevin from episode one however
many years ago right so it's like it
it's knowing that you're on a journey
it's we look at this in black and white
it's like oh I'm not good enough yet and
so I can't share because I haven't
mastered it but you never actually fully
Master anything there's always another
level to continue to expand into and I
write a book uh sorry page in my book
uh and built a serve where like Tony
Robbins isn't even Tony Robbins yeah I
read that right yeah right like you
think of Tony Robbins as the perfect guy
and like he's got it all figured out
doing this for decades and amazing and
and uh and I love Tony he's been like a
huge mentor and inspiration from afar
and in person you know for years now and
I went to his event and uh the first
event that I went to
I went I brought my team and I was
sitting next to two people husband and
wife or boyfriend girlfriend whatever
and like the guy did not want to be
there the girl did want to be there the
guy starts passing out and have you guys
been to Tony Robbins conference uh uh I
saw him in Boston but it wasn't his
conference okay so his guest speaker he
has you jumping and like high-fiving and
hugging people around you and like the
the music is like you have to wear
earplugs this is like blasting and this
guy is asleep next to me asleep like he
fully passed out he paid those tickets
were like 1500 bucks each or something
so you know he paid or somebody paid for
him to be there and he's asleep and
eventually he then leaves and listen
most of the stadium was freaking out
loving it right so no knock on Tony uh
but then he leaves about halfway through
they they won or day two whatever it was
and then the the girlfriend or the wife
or whatever she sticks around for a
little bit and I'm trying to
hug and clap and then she's like losing
energy because he left and I get it I
get it like if Nina left something and
I'm still trying to enjoy and I thought
I would be I would not be happy so like
I would so she eventually left too and
so what it made me realize is like even
Tony is not Tony
and he reviews like a maniac like he'll
he'll review every session afterwards
and meet with his team afterwards like
what went wrong how did we lose one
person and try to improve after Decades
of doing that right it's like what hope
do I have if this guy's been doing it
but it inspired me that he's still not
perfect either so like the the perfect
Tony Robbins is still not perfect Tony
Robbins isn't Tony Robbins and imagine
if you guys or me you know in our
in all of our insecurities and doubts
and fears of being not good enough
imagine if we never shared a piece of
content because we weren't there yet we
hadn't arrived how many people now have
not would not have been served because
of the message so you just have to go
off and create for you on this same
level or climbing the staircase you're
never there you're talking about Tony
reviewing every little detail of who
left and what happened
so how do you make sure that that
doesn't negatively affect your
self-worth to constantly look at the
things that do need to improve you
helped coach us on our YouTube channel
and you're like ah this is the best this
is the worst like because our Channel
wasn't good and and we've come up since
then a little bit but how do you make
sure that that critical nature that's
necessary to become better and to get to
a YouTube channel like you have today
and how critical you have to be about
every thumbnail and every every split
test all that kind of stuff but how do
you make sure that doesn't affect your
self-worth so you're talking like self
are you talking about coaching other
people
both
okay so in myself
I always want to see the negative and
what to improve and it doesn't mean it
doesn't hurt right like some people
leave nasty comments
even on my channel it's all positive
it's all believe it's all inspiration
like we mute out swear words you know
like there's no controversy of pick this
person for president or whatever
um Kanye West is like top ten with
success not top 10 dumbest things he
said or whatever
and we still will get some negativity so
imagine other people's channels who are
controversial whatever uh it doesn't it
still hurts for a second you know like
if somebody says Evan I hate you you're
like though you you made me doubt myself
and I hate my life because of you like
that
for like eight seconds will still hurt
but it's quickly moving past that I just
I just need I need the feedback I need
the feedback to improve to get better
because I don't have all the answers of
where to go next I don't know what to do
next to make it better and a lot of that
can come from my community people
telling me what needs to be fixed
um so you know I have somebody in charge
of helping look and manage after all the
comments on YouTube Instagram whatever
and I want to see the negative ones like
if somebody says hey Evan great job
thank you for this this changed my life
like cool you responded those give me
the negative ones give me the ones that
are critical give me the ones that even
if it's not
um politely said
you know like when people are giving
negative feedback they don't often say
hey Alan Kevin like I love your channel
it's so great but here's just one little
suggestion you know if you tweak this it
might be better but I love you guys and
you're great right like if you can only
accept feedback when it's perfectly
packaged in that gift box you're never
going to learn like it's thrown in all
sorts of negativity and hate comments
but there might be a kernel of Truth
somewhere in there and that's the idea
it's like okay I have empathy for this
person if they're if they're how do
their day is coming to my video that's
positive and leaving some negative
comment how bad a life does this person
have to have right but then inside of
that is there anything that I can
actually
use right so for example
um I was filming here before Danny
pre-danny so we're not throwing Danny
into the bus filming here I had this guy
who was all about his gear and fancy
gear and he had this like red dragon I
don't know how much a red dragon costs
like insanely expensive camera at the
time was like eight years ago or
something
um and like to make it work he had to be
at this end of the studio and I was like
way back here right it's like whatever I
don't care dude set it up put the lights
on I'm gonna go and we filmed an entire
month worth of content in one day
and then when he got home he said Evan I
am so sorry
the microphone wasn't working and I
didn't check properly before we recorded
and so we have now that Danny's got his
headset on so I hope it's coming in
clear
so he says we need to re-film this
because like it sounds like it's
terrible and I said well do we have any
audio it's like yeah but it's only the
auto capture it by my camera which was
like way on the other side of the room
and the camera mic sucks right yeah so I
said you know what we're going to go for
we're going to publish post I don't care
like we make mistakes and we go so for
an entire month on my channel did you at
least amplify it
I don't know what they did my editor
hated me she's like what is this crap
you're giving me like this looks so bad
it's like I'm not refilming it we made a
mistake we're gonna show people that we
make mistakes and we still post anyway
so we post it for an entire month and
some of those videos are actually like
fairly big videos on a channel and the
comments were just rough it's like Evan
why are you filming in a toilet Evan can
I buy you a 50 microphone so like you
should be able to afford this by now on
your YouTube channel it's just like
devastating and like okay it's you know
it's like they're right you know it
sucked I mean they could have positioned
it more nicely than they did but but
they're right and I'm still proud that
we released it imperfectly uh we have a
nice story to tell and whenever I see
that guy again you know I can remind him
of what he did
so one follow-up real quick yeah what
what at the beginning of your journey
were you always this open to negative
feedback
uh
uh was there a time when you were truly
too self-conscious I think it's the same
thing of like this was not an
intentional thing I was trying to get
better at but if you look at what
successful entrepreneur like all the
people that I modeled I've been sharing
their stories I thought I was after just
business success but I learned a lot
about life and being a human
and that's a big thing is like a lot of
these people get hit with negative
feedback one of my favorite uh tweets
right now is Elon Musk a time of like
this recording Elon Musk takes over
Twitter uh everybody says like Twitter
is burning and going away and
um he just lost half his staff and all
other stuff and um this guy tweets out
I'm sitting here and I'm paraphrasing I
won't get it right but I'm sitting here
dealing with my dumb ass imposter
syndrome meanwhile Elon Musk is out
there like breaking everything and
chewing on the wires until the whole
company falls apart right and and I
think I think Twitter is going to make
it I mean I I think Elon uh it's just
moving fast it's like if you take he
wants an army kind of culture and it's a
culture that's not there and he wants to
write people in it but he's not even
defending himself like he cares zero
about what people think about him he's
not saying here's the plan and here's
how I'm working he's like putting mean
pictures up of Jesus and like all sorts
of just random stuff he's not even
trying to defend himself and I look at
that it's like I don't think
I could do that like I think I would
have to be defensive and and just fight
to at least communicate the plane and
what I'm trying to do and he's just
getting destroyed by everybody
like I wouldn't bet against Elon like
he's done this he's the richest man in
the world for a reason right he has a
plan he's just he's not explaining the
plan he's like I don't care I don't need
to explain to you what my plan is I'm
just going to go off and do it and he
doesn't care about the feedback so like
in looking at that
it makes me think how would I handle
that like I would I would hate to go in
and be that type of person like half of
the team leaves overnight so I would
handle it differently but like I respect
the fact that he just doesn't care what
people think about him and another Elon
example was he was on he was on like CNN
or CNBC or whatever and this one stuck
with me where he was saying artificial
intelligence and like the robots are
going to kill take over the world might
kill us all like eventually that's where
it all goes robots kill us all cool
on the National Television right and
then the reporter asked him a bunch of
follow-up questions like well how is it
going to happen he's like I don't know
like and how soon is it gonna happen is
like I don't know and what can we do to
fix it I don't know it's like all of
these questions that he then just
doesn't have the answer to and and what
it made me reflect on was man if I went
on some major news organization and said
some really bull dramatic thing
and then I got asked follow-up questions
and I didn't know the answer
I feel like I would try to stumble
through an answer you know like I feel
like I wouldn't say I don't know
and that made me just pause to think
okay if I ever get asked that a question
I don't know I hope I have the courage
to actually say I don't know and that's
not in the like Elon Musk doesn't have
uh a guy to be Elon Musk right so you
kind of have to read between the lines
and watch this thing happen where a lot
of people might look at him and say well
that's a really stupid or idiotic move
to do it's like yeah okay but dude he's
like the richest man in the world like
maybe he maybe he knows what he's doing
maybe maybe you're the dumbass maybe
like we're thinking about uh but like
those little lessons
seep into me even though I wasn't
consciously going off and seeking them
out just to close the loop because you
said about other people when I asked is
about me or other people when you're
coaching other people I think it really
depends about meeting people where
they're at most people are so uh fragile
and a really almost depressed state that
they can't handle criticism and so
they're like so deep in a hole that they
can't even listen to feedback on how to
get better so the job becomes to get
them above ground and that's love and
encouragement and hug and it's like if I
felt that from you like I was pretty
rough on you guys actually right like
day two when you promised that you were
going to do those thumbnails whatever
and in the morning and I see you and you
haven't done them like what are you
doing dude like you're wasting
everybody's time here right only like I
would not turn up on JP like that
because I don't know GP that well right
I wouldn't do that because I for most
people because they couldn't handle it
because that's like all you come away is
like Evan's such a jackass and then you
still don't go off and do the thumbnails
right so for most people it's
encouragement it's hugs like oh you guys
started a podcast that's amazing even
though I could list a thousand things
that suck about that thing it's it's
it's encouraging the momentum and the
start and and you can always at any
point in time choose to focus on the
positive and the momentum or the
criticism of what needs to be improved
you can always pick for any situation
coming in you're helping somebody with
their fitness plan you can always pick
on the growth that they've had in the
gains and like congratulations or you
can push and say dude like you you
barely are starting right and so
for most people I show up as you
encourager as the believe guy is a
positivity as momentum is like let's go
and like because nobody's cheering them
on for Inner Circle it's much more the
opposite yeah right it's like when Alex
who helps me run Toronto men's house
that comes in with like a big wins like
cool like go celebrate your wins with
somebody else like we suck why are we
still only in one location why are we
right it's like my job as a mentor is at
least I this is my approach to
mentorship is when somebody's coming in
and they feel like they suck I need to
make them feel whole again and when they
feel like they're amazing on top of the
world like you suck and we need to be
over here right now right and so I'm
always basically giving them the
opposite of how they come in feeling and
but they're like nobody's like go
celebrate your way everybody else is
cheering you on Amazing cool I don't
want to celebrate your wins I want to
know like how we're going to go off and
change the world because nobody talks to
people in that way you know people would
look at your your channel back to that
moment and say man you've done so many
episodes like you're growing it's great
you just partner with Dave Meltzer I
think at the time and like all these
great things are happening awesome dude
where's the thumbnails you promised me
thumbnail else you didn't get them done
I'm pissed let's go like I'm pissed for
you because you are holding yourself
back right and then you're gonna do it
on the plane and you take a video or
whatever you think it's great I try to
get you I try to win you back yeah it's
great it's like I still remember that
stuff but I forget everything else like
I figured so many other things that I
remember that right and so I think
that's what a great
when you're a great coach does you have
to understand where the person is at
right now and what do they need the most
help with and most of the time it's just
a hug to get back because they're so
buried and they hate themselves so much
when they look at themselves in the
mirror you just have to get them back to
like being a okay human and not being on
the ground but once they're once they're
above ground then becomes the push okay
now we're not in the hug business it's
like now we need to push and start to
fly well I will say this out of all the
coaches we've had mentors we've had you
are the one that we always go back to as
being the best so I appreciate the push
and it's been wonderful and I'm not just
saying that because we're on camera
we obviously this conversation is about
what are the top five things that you
wish you knew as an early entrepreneur
what is the number one thing you wish
you knew and I want to add a second part
because I kind of have an idea of
probably where that will go you're in a
thousand so there's a room there's a
thousand entrepreneurs early
entrepreneurs and you're giving it to
them straight what do you think they
need to know the number one thing
contextually
so I used to hate this question because
you know like I can't go back and help
myself from 19 and tell them what to do
um
but I ended up liking this question
because whatever your answer to that
question is you still need right now
like whatever you would tell
19 year old Kevin
is the same thing that 85 year old Kevin
would tell Kevin right now so then it
actually becomes practical right as
opposed to because it's like the number
one question I get asked on podcast like
what would you tell your 19 year old
self cool and they're like give an
answer but I hate this question but it's
actually practical because I still need
it right now and for me the answer is
belief like I need more belief right I
need that more belief if I was what am I
trying to share the world more belief
what's the problem with everybody and if
I didn't know anything I had zero
context on the audience like the problem
is belief you don't believe in yourself
do the next thing you think the problem
is how how do I X that's not the problem
the problem is you don't believe in
yourself to do the how I can give you
all the hows in the world but until you
believe in your ability to do the how
you're not going to do the thing is
there such thing as too much belief or
rather delusional belief how do you
separate accurate thinking of oneself
from belief
um I don't know because I haven't really
encountered it you know like does that
you think about the Steve Jobs reality
Distortion field that's exactly right
yeah
but did he believe too much because he
created amazing things right you know
and and like he made things happen when
when other people couldn't or didn't
think that it was possible so can you
believe too much maybe I mean I think I
guess at some point
you believe that aliens are uh beating
you up every night when you go to sleep
I don't know like I'm sure at some point
that you move off into a land of mental
health that then is Not Practical or
safe uh but in entrepreneur land
um I think as long as you're I'm not I
haven't identified as like the biggest
risk taker so
you look at Walt Disney and he like
bankrupted himself twice to build Disney
like put all of it twice like I don't
think I would ever do that I know I
watched her for
sure no I don't know when we go to
Disney World I uh
will often have like it's super boring
this is one exhibit at Disney World
where it's Disney's story and how he
started Disney story so uh when we go
like Nina and the kids will go to the
Indiana Jones Adventure like show where
Indiana Jones is being followed by
Boulder and like beating the bad guys
and action sequence and it's like an
hour show whatever and I'll like slowly
Meander through the history of Walt
Disney with like his early cartoons and
the stories it's like man this guy is
just it's unbelievable what he what he
created what like the belief in himself
to go off and do it the risk and
everything twice to go make it happen I
find that really inspiring and it's it
forces self-reflection to I I definitely
am not the person who would do that
right now
could I become that maybe but it
definitely forces inspiration and
self-reflection to say
Okay I uh I need to step up my game you
obviously have a wonderful team and a
wonderful family Nina do you
has this journey been lonelier
than you expected or like what has that
been like for you the relationship
aspect meeting other people what has
that been like
I I'm an introvert and I loved solo so
growing up in my first in my first
businesses I've only had three long-term
relationships in my life and
Nina's the best of course right not just
because she's here hello
we just celebrated 10 years together in
Paris congratulations last week that was
fine or two weeks ago when when I got
started I would always do my thing and
then my partner would just do her own
thing and like it was always separate
and I never felt like I needed anything
either so it's also on me for not
communicating like I just never thought
okay I'm gonna go speak at this event
I'm gonna go do this thing okay I'll see
you when I come back whatever and then
when I met Nina she's like can I come
like I'm just talking business stuff
like he's an entrepreneurs it's gonna be
boring he's meeting people it's like oh
okay cool can I come it's like well I
mean if you want it's like really
important I'm trying to Pepper for like
because if you're not an entrepreneur
you're with entrepreneurs I don't know
it could be really boring like I don't
want to she was in HR I don't want to go
to HR conference and learn about this
like I want to poke my eyes up before
going to HR conference
um but she wanted to come like okay yeah
sure I mean I want to see what you do
okay cool come so she came and she sat
in the front row and watched and it's
like huh you know what it's like kind of
cool to have somebody like who's with
you who wants to support you and sit
through your stuff right and I didn't
realize how valuable it actually was
right and So eventually Nina quit her
job and how long have you been like five
years
I don't know
right before our trip before we went on
the tour yeah so three years I guess
three years full time uh joined join the
company and it's been it's like I think
it's the best dude I love where I mean I
know how you guys work together I love
working with friends I love working with
family I think it's the best I think if
you can communicate I think the problem
is communication and expectations but I
love working with family
um I have a very low need to be
with people as long as I have like Nina
if I didn't have Nina I'd probably be
going out and talking to people more and
salsa dancing or doing more events or
whatever but if Nina I was like oh yeah
I'm good this is fine like I like doing
every now and then events and having
people come up but
um yeah that was surprising how how
little I thought it was I needed it and
they're like wow this is actually really
really cool I'm glad that I stumbled
into it how much has that changed I know
we're at the point now where I'm on so
many podcasts that it's like I don't
want to do this I I wanted this and I
wanted to be in front of so many people
and now it's like wow this is a lot did
you have a a certain level where you got
to the top of that where you're like
okay I have enough people I want to go
recluse more and be more of an introvert
than an extrovert I think that that is
just a self-awareness thing and knowing
how many you want to do like I still
fight to be on podcasts like I I love it
it's super fun it is it is I love it
when I get to the moment where it's like
oh man I don't want then I'm out it's
done like forget it I'm not doing that
anymore whether it's the person or just
the whole thing in general I'll move on
but I I do a lot of podcasts that I
shouldn't be doing like I'll be
somebody's first guest on their podcast
ours was one of them
yes was it no it wasn't the first but we
were we were grateful you did it
considering the other things I'm
supposed to be doing and and like my
team is like I need you for this like
yeah but I told these guys again yeah so
uh I fight for because it's still fun
for me however many I like seeing the
growth too like I love like you guys
coming back this is the third time or
fourth time or whatever fifth time I
don't know from the time like I've met
you from like Pittsburgh I remember the
Airbnb we were in where we did the you
know call on the phone
um oh yeah
that was our first time and I gave you
extra time and that was after a whole
day of like driving to Pittsburgh and
doing podcasts all day long that day you
were my last one and it was supposed to
be done by the time I got into the
Airbnb and then relax and then I just
kept going with you while these guys
unpacked the car and everything I just
kept going with you guys because you
were asking a lot of behind the scenes
she's like our goal is to pull back the
curtain on what success really I like
really liked that line I really love
your questions like I like these guys uh
so we extended it uh and then it turned
into I don't know how many other shows
or interactions or whatever over the
years and when I thought about this idea
it's like I'm gonna call you guys first
and I could see see if they're free and
message to you and like hey what are you
guys doing on Twitter yeah he's like
yeah I think we got like half an hour
open or something on the day he's like
oh okay well here's what I'm thinking
and like you want to do it cool not uh
you know whatever like hey yeah we're
coming Okay cool so the last two hours
is gonna be dedicated to these guys but
if I was doing it every day all day I
wouldn't
the the as as great as it feels
uh it's diminishing returns and then I'm
not it's not I don't know if it would
ever get negative I don't know if I'd
ever do so many podcasts it would turn
negative but uh I would probably either
get sick like physically sick because
this is what happens to me when I go to
events and I spend too much time talking
to people I don't even notice that I'm
getting sick and then I like fall apart
so I think before saying I hate this I
would get sick
uh and I would feel bad that I'm not
making progress on my other projects I'm
not moving my software company forward
I'm not building my YouTube channel I'm
not being there for my team I'm not
doing the things that I need to do Alex
said that you're the type of person who
wakes up in the morning and you can't
wait to get to work
he said that he's not as like that as
you are for an early entrepreneur that
might be out there watching what would
you suggest to them if that's not their
predisposition because I in that moment
I realized I'm that way too more so than
yeah I'm not that way um what would you
recommend to someone you wake up and
you're like I hate life or what do you
no no I don't like I don't want to work
oh yeah I have to like I think I have to
force myself less than Alan because Alan
is a visionarian is connected to an
outcome where I'm just like yeah just
tell me what to do man I think it takes
him more self-discipline to get going
and then once he's rolling he does
really well but I don't want to do much
else
yeah you need to feel connected to the
mission
like if if you woke up every day and
felt like today was going to matter you
would show up differently
like the problem is today whatever it
could I could make it I could not make
it whatever it doesn't matter like if
you if you woke up every day and uh what
time do you wake up good usually 4 30.
cool so if like at five o'clock every
morning you had a coaching call with
somebody from Next Level University a
listener
you would wake up hate your life not
hate your life whatever like I use that
figuratively but you wake up and be uh
grumpy or just tired or whatever not
like hating life but like not not the
captain we all know and love you
wouldn't want to do the call like oh I
wanted to [ __ ] call it's five in the
morning why am I doing this call it's so
dumb right you [ __ ] and moan and
complain and then you do the call and
then be a you'd be like this is amazing
guys oh my God Next Level University is
like the greatest thing ever let's go
and keep building right the the problem
is a disconnect from the mission that
you're on
uh and so it needs to be forced whether
that's uh Alan coming in and saying
Kevin you know get out of bed let's go
work on this thing or you know you're
coming to Toronto to film a show or
whatever
um so that that like that's the thing
that's missing if you if you had a 5 a.m
call with somebody for half an hour in
your community you would be completely
you would hate the first half hour of
your day and then you'd be charged up
to go and serve like they would in that
half hour of talking to them you would
wake up and then have fire to go crush
the day yeah
I'm definitely I just want to put it out
there I definitely love what we do it's
just I'm not as with him that's all it
is like he doesn't ever turn off for me
I need to shut down or to your point
like I do get sick I get run down I lose
my voice where he's just a machine he
keeps going so I just want to put that
out there yeah but that's different like
getting run down is different than
waking up and not being like jazz to go
and do the thing that you're going to do
yeah I'm jazzed but if you left me a
fair in full disclosure if you left me
alone to my own devices odds are I would
get way less done
but I do love what we do more than
anything that's why I've traded my life
essentially for it I love it more than
anything but I do require and this is
I'll turn this to a question
an early entrepreneur how do they know
if they require somebody to help them
stay on track because I think you're a
self-starter where I'm not necessarily
as much as you and Alan are
I think I think you it's like you know
like you wait like you know that you're
not much of a self-starter like you can
look at your entire history of the
things that you've worked on do you need
to be accountable to somebody else
or can you go off and just start
building things so the way like again
the only thing missing for you and we're
being hard on you but with with like
we're not you're not garbage
right that's like the defense mechanism
comes in because like it feels like
we're beating up and like but we're not
calling you garbage the problem is
you're in the Navy you know awesome and
it's hard to get into the Navy and it's
Kick-Ass to be in the Navy and you got
to wake up at five in the morning and do
whatever you need to do in the Navy
right awesome I want you to be Navy
Seals and that's the only difference so
you know the Navy Seals will look at the
names like yeah those guys are kind of
trash but you're not really trash right
like to the general world you're not
trash but you could be Navy Seals you
could have a lot more energy and you
could be a lot more focused on the
mission and what you're doing so that
left your own devices you don't just
Coast right and even though coasting for
you is like a thousand times better than
what most of America does right that's
not who we're comparing yourself to
right
go be an ABCO but so like you need
something in the schedule if you're not
a self-starter as much you need
something in the schedule to to hold you
accountable like you would work out
better if you had a gym buddy where you
had a trainer who's going to meet you at
the train at the gym or meet you on zoom
and show you how to do whatever you had
to do because you'll show up for that
person right so you need somebody you
don't need like you'll do better if you
have a training call at 5am you sell it
as a bonus package like hey you get
Kevin at five in the morning just what
everybody wants somebody people will pay
for that
you have 30 different people it's once a
month ten thousand dollars a year to
have Kevin talked you for half an hour
once a month and now it's it's for you
yeah
and now you're on fire every morning
you're gonna hate your life every
morning if you're gonna wake up at 4 30
you're gonna You're Gonna Hate Evan
Carmichael for this stupid idea you
can't believe you can do this again I
hate that guy why did I ever go to
Toronto I want to punch his face in and
then you're gonna go and you're gonna do
the call and then you're gonna love life
and you're gonna be on fire welcome the
Navy SEAL mode
how do you uh and again I want to bring
this into the top five things you wish
you knew at the beginning
what used to drive you back then to get
to Navy SEAL level or who should I say
who helped helped you stay accountable
or was it always self-accountability
stories
right like the stories of of uh
successful people like Walt Disney yeah
all of that like I would read this book
my favorite one of my favorite books
it's actually not that great a book but
it was one of my favorite books at the
time uh it's called radicals and
Visionaries
Thaddeus warro I think is the author
it's out of print that you can't even
find it because I hate reading like I'm
a slow reader so it's not the best way
for me to learn but at the time when I
was getting started YouTube wasn't a
thing uh there were no videos to watch
So reading was the only option so I
would read but why this book was so
great is it would tell you a story of
Jeff Bezos or whoever in three to four
pages like the whole story in three to
four pages with some good quotes and
motivations like this is great I wake up
sounds like your YouTube channel exactly
right that's what it is right so instead
of I would not I wouldn't read the whole
book I'd like just wake up
read the read uh one story it's I
wouldn't panic because there's only
three or four pages in his pictures and
stuff and quotes and like blurbs you
know so like this is an easy read and I
feel inspired after reading it like yes
I'm gonna go off and do this thing
um that's why if you look at it now it's
like this is the book that it made you
so like it's not that great a book but
my YouTube channel is basically an
homage to that where and a lot of people
like I wake up and I still watch my
videos other people wake up and they set
their morning to watching the video off
my channel because they're they want
Elon Musk and Tony Robbins and Oprah
Winfrey and whoever in their head
because it it pulls them up to the next
level you talk often about belief that's
that's your one word that's the through
line that's the thing that you've
struggled with that's the thing that
you've leaned into what are you the best
in the world at
being Evan Carmichael
you know and there's another Urban
Carmichael in Hawaii so me and him we
got that a little bit he's a pastor in
Hawaii so he also talked about belief
yeah he's a pastor in Hawaii named Evan
Carmichael who talks about believe and
so We've joked every now and then that
like I'm gonna I'm gonna go and we're
gonna do something together in Hawaii
the believe believe
there's no one specific skill you know I
think I think I have an ability to help
people believe
in themselves more than they they do
right like I'll believe in them more
than they believe in themselves am I the
best in the world at it I don't know I
think lots of people have that ability
but it's a pretty rare ability
um it's like I'm in the NBA am I the am
I the Michael Jordan of that I don't
know but I'm definitely in the NBA of it
um but the the only thing you can be the
best the best in the world that is
yourself so I'm the best Canadian Evan
Carmike
uh when you were talking earlier about
coaching someone
and you were talking about sometimes you
have to challenge them if they're
feeling good and get them to aim higher
sometimes you have to really get them to
ground level because their self-esteem
is hurting or their belief or whatever
uh do you factor someone's aspirations
into that in terms of like because you
said it the important piece is knowing
where they are now yeah but do you also
look at where they're headed or where
they want to head because in my coaching
I understand that okay here's where you
are self-awareness here's where you
think you want to go but where you
actually want to go is here from my
perspective
do you factor that in when you challenge
people because what I've found is if
they don't have a huge aspiration it's
difficult for them to take the feedback
and not villainize you
like how did you know yeah I mean it's
the only way you can push somebody is if
you know if if you know what they want
and they know that you know what they
want right right like but if if somebody
doesn't have aspirations
you can't even push them on anything
like why are you put of course they're
going to build on is you because they
hate their own life if they have no
imagine somebody has no aspirations in
life that's not a happy person right so
you coming in and yelling them and
saying you should have aspirations like
forget it
there's no way they're going to listen
to you even if you're saying the right
thing you just you're saying the right
thing at the wrong time in the wrong way
so yeah you have to know what what they
want out of life and if they don't know
then that becomes the next job is to
help them figure out what it is that
they want and then helping them believe
in the thing that they want
have I sensed was there any frustration
have you tried to help people that
didn't have aspiration and it was a
waste of time and effort or I guess
what's your relationship with that I
don't see anything as a waste of time
and effort it's more uh did I do my best
if anything for me
I lean I lean too much on the believe
encouragement and not enough on the push
so bring me your thing like I'll chew
you on like oh my gosh it's amazing
we'll do an Instagram thing it's like
let's get like you guys wasn't quite our
experience I'm just joking until I know
right my so this happened I used to run
this Mastermind in Toronto and there was
this entrepreneur who joined and he
was uh
I saw where his business was going and
and I gave him the advice on what to do
and he didn't do it and it ended up
tanking his company and like
I saw the company tanking if you didn't
do it right so I like saw the path and
I'd seen it before with other people
like pattern recognition like you need
to go off and do this and I wasn't hard
enough it was a suggestion like hey you
know what like if you did this here's a
little idea for you maybe right and he
didn't do it and and so I listen
ultimately this is their business he'd
made the decision whatever but I feel
like I played I took it as that's my
fault
because I didn't do my best to show up
for that person
because I was too like soft and
cheerleader mode like yeah okay you can
figure it out that way too whatever but
not enough of a of a hard push to say no
no like this this is what's gonna happen
so if I did my best to show up for that
person we had trust and we had Rapport
and I could have done it I could have
been harsher so that's where I needed to
like I need to push faster
if I have all those things lined up
right you know so I need to work on the
opposite I don't need to work on being
nicer I need to work on being harsher I
should push him more like I should have
pushed you more like that was soft that
was still soft what so we've been
traveling for the last couple weeks I
thought it was the perfect amount we've
been traveling for the last couple weeks
one of the reasons we love traveling is
because we have so many lessons because
we're out of our Echo chamber there's
different stuff traveling different
environments what is the and this is one
of my favorite questions what is the
most recent lesson you have learned that
is sticking with you and it's changed
the way that you show up every day
that great ideas flow through me
and so
a lot of times when we get a great idea
or you get an idea we what's what's the
first thing that happens we get an idea
a lot of times we get a little excited
and then not even telling our friends
you're not even going to tell Alan's
immediately like oh I don't know if we
can do that I don't have time for that
like it's our own voice to tell us that
we can't do these things right
maybe you then go tell somebody and
chances other people in your family
friends not you guys but in general like
then that your wife tells you you can't
do it your girlfriend tells you can't do
it your friends whatever you're gonna go
do a fun you're gonna go do that Danny
you're gonna quit FedEx to be a
videographer are you crazy like you
can't do that stupid right we tell
people and they they crash our dreams
even more
uh where I just had a flip is like okay
because I came up with the idea
therefore it's good and so I'm gonna do
it
shortcuts the you've been doing that
yeah
from that yeah what's the most recent
this like here how long ago did I
message you about this two weeks yeah
it's like it's not tons of time I came
with the idea is like I want to do
something in person
huh okay
I need Danny Danny what are you doing on
November 22nd right it's like yeah I can
make it perfect good I think I actually
gave Danny three dates
and some of them were sooner like one of
it might have been like that week or
something like 7 14 and 22 or whatever
right and he's like I can't do these two
I'll do the I could but I can do this
one it's like okay so do I stay I like I
would pick Danny over anybody else if
you can't make any of them okay fine
I'll find somebody else Danny said
November 22nd cool now we need to go
what are we gonna do what are we gonna
do on on the day I want to get four
coaching sessions I want to do
you know two or four podcasts uh and
okay let's start out reaching and it all
happened really fast and just in that
momentum like great things happen what's
it all gonna look like I don't know I
don't know like it's literally playing
it as we go this is this is an
experiment this could have all like
everybody showed up this is a miracle
Uncle fluent from Dubai to be here right
it's crazy yeah it all happened you
could have got stopped at the border you
know Canadians think you're a terrorist
I don't know like
so many things could have gone wrong but
like it all worked out and we're here
and if it went wrong like you guys
couldn't show up cool JP's gonna
interview me for two hours
surprise right like we'll just we'll
flow with it and make it happen if
somebody else couldn't make it for the
master for like the one-on-one is cool I
was like okay hey Alan you want to be in
like yeah cool no awesome we'll grab
somebody from hey you want to be
coaching like just the trust that the
idea is good as long as you're in a good
like you're in service you're feeling
elevated you're feeling alive you get an
idea trust that it's a great idea and
just go do something about it instead of
overthinking over analyzing over judging
and so this thing all happens it
literally was happening like as we go
right it started off with the four
people to do the coaching it's like okay
but we still have two hours in the
afternoon what are we gonna do oh you
know I wonder what Kevin and Alan are
doing maybe we should have them come up
and maybe you guys can't make it cool
okay I wonder what like whoever else is
available and I'll find somebody else to
make it happen
um then no maybe I need somebody to help
like navigate things so you know Megan
my niece is like helping bring people up
and down we should should do a dinner
maybe she did dinner like maybe people
would like to dinner afterwards like are
people sticking around are they just
gonna go home it'd be fun because I only
see people one-on-one you guys are
having all these group experiences like
I'm only here so it'd be fun to have a
group experience and have dinner right
and so this might be like the next great
thing that I do every month and I'm and
I'm selling it and it's amazing or I
never do it again and like who cares but
it just happened two weeks ago and like
here we all are right now doing it and
so just trusting that the idea like it
just shortcuts your brain because your
brain usually sucks at the beginning
your brain helps you figure out the how
but your brain can't figure out the why
so you get this y you get this great
idea that then doesn't make sense like I
can't do that why would I do that that's
stupid and your brain takes over and
then you've already lost so it's like
okay I got the idea therefore it's good
because great ideas flow through me and
if that sounds too egotistical or
whatever it's like okay well like it
comes from God great ideas are coming
from above and like now you're quenching
the spirit like go do something right
and you go off and you create and it it
sometimes turns into amazing things it's
never
like completely backfired right
um and like the what's the worst case of
of today like nobody shows up and I pay
Danny to be here and we catch up and we
film our own podcast together I don't
know right but just like listening to
that voice trusting that it's right and
doing something about it what would the
inner dialogue have been at the
beginning for you I don't have time for
this
I'm only going to get eight videos if I
was doing solo videos I'd get way more
than eight videos out of this I got a
million things to do I've got team
members that I'm not following up with
I've got software company that I need to
be building I've got like all the other
responsibilities that I say are
important that are important and like
this is a waste of time what questions
are going to have am I going to be good
enough you know uh all sorts of stuff
that is easy to seep in
and but by committing to it like as soon
as Danny said yes okay well now we're
doing it yeah
it's November 22nd now we have now it
has to happen so you brought it to Danny
and then it was done kind of because
after that I mean it was already kind of
done like if Danny couldn't make it I
give him three weeks right three options
and listen it was a tight deadline like
hey when is this week I don't know what
he's doing right but if Danny couldn't
have done it he he would have given me
somebody like every time I've asked
Danny for yourself then he can't do it
he gives me he gives me one somebody on
his team he gives me his business
partner like somebody else to come in
and do it so I knew that even by
reaching out to Danny if Danny was super
tied up or hated me or whatever I don't
want to do your stupid sessions anymore
okay cool he would say hey hire JB or
hire Anthony or higher Katie or hire
somebody else so I I knew in the
Outreach from that first message it was
already going to happen because there's
no way it's like there's no way that
Danny would let me down and not give me
some kind of option so even if he
couldn't do it something was going to
happen right same thing in reaching out
to you guys like the idea of being able
to do a show format was going to happen
as soon as I came up with it I thought
of you guys first if you couldn't make
it whatever with totally legit reasons
like it's not like I gave you tons of
time to figure this out you had a full
day plan with only half an hour free
right cool I would have found somebody
else right it wouldn't have been nearly
as good of course I would have found
somebody else to do it like by already
sending a message I had committed to it
to the four people who we had downstairs
who then were coming up I didn't know
who the four people were going to be
right but by even like sending the first
message out I was committing that we
were going to do this thing
um and I think that's what's missing for
most people it's like you're just not
not committing to the first step
how long have you operated that way
or something yeah but more like there
wasn't like one moment like oh like oh
wow that's where I sucked and I need to
do more of it it's it's in I think you
need to prove to yourself that yeah that
you're building a credibility like to
say great ideas flow through me okay but
really I could prove it
so like that's a test so this was a test
and it ended up you know I come back
from this like this is fun I don't know
if you guys had fun or what I had fun
this is great I'm loving this this is I
don't even know what I'm supposed to be
doing today but this is awesome right
it's like I want to do more
uh so that's a good sign because if
you're if you love like the process of
the work that you're doing you should go
off and do more of it
um so every time you
every time you take one step it gives
you the motivation and and belief to go
take the next step and the next step and
the next step I woke up this morning so
hyped to come in it was like this is
gonna oh it works this is so good I'm so
excited I don't know who's up next who's
up first it doesn't matter let's go
we're gonna have a blast so we came with
four topics yeah and I know we're going
all over and that's like you said we're
winging it we're gonna figure out what
happens yeah you're you seem like
somebody who has a very very strong fail
forward mentality is what is your
default is your default fail feel bad
get better like how was it when you're
doing a Walt Disney video in a tuxedo
however many years ago versus now when
it comes to things
I was in a suit yeah yeah so how serious
how I need to do a tuxedo video how is
your failed forward changed because one
of the things we're going to talk about
is unlayering
the relationship you have with failure
you've done so many videos and you've
made so many mistakes but you keep
showing up and I think a lot of people
would have quit long before they got to
this part what was your relationship
with failure like in the beginning
versus now okay well let's make that the
next video
so guys if you want to see my
relationship to failure
go watch the video right there we'll see
you there believe